Hello?
Jessica Jones...
you are a cheater.
You were given
every advantage.
Allowed to make mistake
after mistake.
You can't control yourself.
You have no discipline,
just brute force.
What do you want?
I want you to die.
Gregory Salinger. He's smarter
than both of us combined.
I don't know about that.
I know who you are.
It's not exactly a secret.
So, you know
I can break your face?
-I barely survived him.
-Salinger did this.
Let's go get him.
I don't need your help,
and you don't need mine.
He was unjustly arrested.
When you cozy up to maniacs,
people around you get hurt.
Everybody's got a story.
A beginning, a middle,
an end.
-I'm late for work.
-As what?
Super cat burglar?
You know what, Jess?
You do it your way.
I'm gonna do it my way.
There's still a way this ends
with me respecting you.
That's not my highest priority
right now.
Jessica Jones...
you believed
that you could save the world,
but you're terrified
you've already failed them.
And you have,
because you are not,
and you never will be,
a hero.
Are you still a hero
if nobody thinks you are?
Like I give a shit
what other people think.